antoine qu'est ce qui s'est dit
exactement entre les deux chefs d'état
les deux dirigeants se sont tout d'abord
souhaité la bonne année comme le veulent
les usages diplomatiques
ensuite le communiqué publié par le
kremlin nous informe qu'il a donc été
question du possible production
conjointe deux vaccins le dialogue
devant maintenant continuer au niveau
des ministères de la santé et autres
organismes concernés alors bien sûr tout
cela reste encore très vagues les
contours de cette coopération reste en
effet toujours à définir
à l'heure actuelle la campagne de
vaccination à l'aide du spoutnik v a
démarré en russie depuis le 5 décembre
mais des lots en société vous envoyer en
biélorussie en serbie et en argentine
l'algérie le brésil ou encore la guinée
devraient leur emboîter le pas la
hongrie a elle reçu six mille doses du
spoutnik vais dès le mois de novembre
mais devrait malgré tout se détourner de
lui détourner de ce vaccin craignant les
capacités de production limitées du
vaccin russe et c'est peut-être en 5e
cette coopération russo allemande
pourrait être bénéfique
ce ne serait de toute façon pas la
première collaboration entre la russie
et l'europe en termes de vaccins contre
le coc vide
le 11 décembre en effet le laboratoire
suédo britannique astrazeneca et moscou
ont annoncé leur volonté de combiner
leurs deux vaccins et c'est sans doute
de cette façon par la mise en commun et
la combinaison de tous ces savoir-faire
que l'on pourra efficacement lutter
contre cette pandémie
merci antoine cléroux en direct de
moscou en russie